I come from Bali a very small island in
Indonesia the island is mostly known
around the world as a very popular
tourist destination with its beautiful
landscapes clear blue beaches and most
importantly it's very unique culture and
tradition every single year in Bali we
celebrate the Balinese new year also
known as noopy it is a day of silence
for the Balinese people no one is
allowed to leave their houses no one is
allowed to light any fire or use any
devices that are emitting light
including television and lamps during
the day it'll be very quiet and peaceful
there'd be no more sounds of cars or
motorbikes passing by at night it would
be pitch black complete darkness there
would be no form of lights not even the
light of the moon since it's also during
the lunar eclipse now it's a very young
child I've always been terrified of the
dark and I couldn't bear the thought
that I have to go through these same
nights every single year I've always
thought that we were alone that we were
the only people in the world still
living like cavemen but the older I got
the more I realized that one day in a
year without light is not so bad after
all I realized that I was in fact not
alone and that there are over a billion
people around the world who are going
through the same nights that I feared
every single day of their lives I've
grown to appreciate this tradition and
see it not only the simple holiday but
as a reminder to me that there are
people out there living without light
and that we should do our best to help
them I've experienced a day of what it
felt like for there's 1.2 billion people
around the world who have no access to
electricity and what struck me the most
was finding out that a large proportion
of these people live near the equator
where sunlight is most abundant coming
from a tropical island myself the Sun
has always inspired me the amount of
heat coming to my room in the afternoon
is enough to convince me that the Sun is
indeed very powerful it made me wonder
why is it that our use of solar energy
today is still very minimal to
understand how we got here in the first
place
let's take a look at a brief history of
how we humans discovered new sources of
energy far before the Industrial
Revolution we all started simply by
burning wood to keep ourselves warm in
the mid 19th century we all started
hunting for whales in the vast and empty
oceans for their oils to light
illuminant lamps at home we then
explored underground for coal and oil to
power our steam engines and factories
recently we started harnessing nuclear
energy to meet our growing energy
consumption what's fascinating is that
throughout the centuries of discoveries
the Sun has always been present it has
always been right up there but we'd
rather look underground and underwater
for energy instead well I'm not blaming
the people of the past because they
simply didn't have the technology or
understanding on how to capture the
sun's energy but today in a world far
more technologically advanced than
before I believe we could do much better
the economies of the world today are
growing at an exponential rate but the
nature of that growth itself is quite
unhealthy and unsustainable due to the
amount of pollution we emit if we are
ever to maintain this rate of growth we
need to make a change a change towards a
cleaner alternative energy source many
countries around the world are already
putting their best efforts in this
transition both for the International
commitment to reduce air pollution and
the positive prospects of solar energy
their own economies Portugal in May 2016
was part for four days entirely from
renewable energies that include wind
hydro and solar power China and India
are both planning to nearly triple their
solar capacities in a few years time
Japan started building floating solar
farms that plans to par nearly 5,000
households by early 2018 and Germany
seven percent of the total electricity
consumption has already come from solar
energy you see these are signs these
commitments made by these countries are
signs that they have realized the
importance and significance of solar
energy and now now it's up to us to
decide whether or not we should welcome
this change and whether or not we should
push it to the next level many people
would assume that a solar dependent
feature is too optimistic or is
impossible well I want you all to take a
look at this picture right here what's
do you see many people would say well
that's just the rainforest what I see is
a civilization a very prosperous
civilization which has flourished
throughout our planet for a great deal
of our planets history using the energy
from the Sun and if they are capable of
doing such things then I believe we
could do it too in fact this Sun
delivers more energy to our planet in
just one hour one hour than we consume
and an entire year with our current
solar technology which has an efficiency
around 20% it is estimated that we need
an area around about the size of Spain
to power the entire world now keep in
mind that I said with our current solar
technology if that efficiency doubles
that we will need half of that area now
the area of Spain itself may look very
big but actually if all the countries of
the world
devotes just 0.4% of their land area for
a solar farm that would add up the size
of Spain and also keep in mind that I
said land area I didn't even consider
the area of the ocean which by the way
covers 71% of this planet's surface in
fact we could fit in over 700 Spain's on
our ocean today and we only need the
area of one Spain so far the entire
world and when I talk about these facts
about areas I'm not only talking about
those solar farms with neatly arranged
solar panels I'm also talking about the
actions of individuals like you and I
and how significant and impact we could
make if we all acted collectively take a
smartphone as an example the average
energy needed to charge a smartphone in
a year is approximately three kilowatt
hours that is roughly the same energy
that could lift a 1000 ton object or on
180 adult elephants one meter above the
ground could you believe that the small
phones that you're carrying in your
pockets every day takes up the same
energy in a year that could lift 180
adult elephants one meter around three
feet above the ground now that is just
one phone there's an S there's an
estimated 2.3 billion smartphone users
in the world today and in that case the
total energy needed to charge all the
phones smartphones in the world per year
would be seven billion kilowatt hours
the same energy that could power an
additional six hundred thousand average
American households we could light the
homes of over six hundred thousand more
people with the energy we use to charge
our smart phones if we were instead to
charge our phones with devices like
solar part battery packs that amount of
energy could actually be saved for those
who can't afford electricity if
individuals start contributing and
generating just small amounts of energy
to power even the smallest things like
phones and lamp
that energy saved would add up to
something much much bigger fortunately
in today's modern world there are
already many inventions out there that
could help us do this an example would
be Tesla soda roof tiles which may cost
more than a regular roof tiles at first
it can actually be cheaper in the long
run if you consider the cuts in your
electricity bills
and with the rise of other inventions
like solar part vehicles I believe this
industry has a potential to continue
growing and possibly dominate future
markets now let's not only talk about
the good things there are many problems
and limitations to solar energy that we
cannot ignore but let's also take a look
at some possible solutions to overcome
them as well now the first and most
common arguments against solar panels is
that they are too expensive now there
are no disagreements that I could make
here because they are they are very
expensive but I can say the price of
solar panels has been falling
drastically over the past 40 years the
price of a solar panel back in the mid
1970s was around about $80 per watt and
today that has fallen to less than $1
per watt that is over a hundred times
cheaper than what it was 40 years ago
and in some countries today solar energy
is already cheaper than alternatives
like fossil fuel people are no longer
using solar energy because they are
cleaner but because they are more
profitable and let's face it that's what
most of us think about and the second
problem with solar energy is that they
are inconsistent solar panels don't work
as well on tiny days and they don't work
at all up nights at times and most
individuals need energy however what the
availability of batteries we could store
these energy generated from sunny days
and use them at times when we need them
and finally last problem associated with
solar energy is that sunlight is
unevenly distributed across our planet
countries in the northern and southern
hemisphere tend to receive less sunlight
than those in their equator and some of
those countries may not be able to rely
on solar energy just yet
those countries could instead look
towards
forms of renewable energy such as a
biofuel geothermal or wind until a
possible solution in the future could be
found now despite all these issues that
I've talked about we must all be
reminded the very important fact that
the world today is slowly running out of
fossil fuel putting the problem
pollution aside we must all understand
that the fossil fuel cannot keep us
running forever the fossil fuel that we
are using today have accumulated from
the past millions and millions of
centuries and we have used up so much of
them in only 250 years it has even
predicted that we will completely run
out of fossil fuel by the next fifty to
a hundred years and if we are not
seriously committed on replacing these
fossil fuel then we and the future
generations may not be able to enjoy the
things that are available to us today
especially in a world faced with issues
like global warming and climate change
solar energy should be met with more
open arms and maybe one day when the
whole world looks up into the Sun and
when those billions could finally light
up their homes
I could once again look up into the
night sky of nippy day back in Bali not
scared but deeply deeply satisfied
knowing that we are in fact the only
people in the world still living in the
dark like cavemen thank you
[Applause]